we are the guardians of the Republic
that's that's how we really see
ourselves and it's important that our
country sees us that way also I'm Dave
Rubin and joining me on the Rubin report
today or two u.s. combat veterans one a
former member of the US Congress and one
a former MMA champion Colonel Allen West
and Chad Robicheaux welcome to the Rubin
report thanks today I am glad to have
you guys here because as I mention to
you right before we started we haven't
done enough generally on military and
veterans issues and and all of those
things so we're gonna dive into all that
talk about your nonprofit and why you
guys are here together and all of those
good things but first off what made each
of you want to go into the military
colonel I'll start with you well for me
it was a family tradition you know we
just celebrated the 75th anniversary of
d-day well my father fought in World War
two he was a corporal in United States
Army he initially started in North
Africa Sicily Italy and that's where he
was wounded rena supplied dispatches my
older brother was a marine infantryman
and vietnam wounded a caisson and at the
age of 15 my dad challenged me to be the
first officer in our family so i went
through high school Junior ROTC in
Atlanta what did fifteen-year-old Island
West think about that 15-year Allen West
wanted to you know follow his dad's lead
and I think that that is why positive
strong role models male role models so
important in the black community because
my dad gave me a direction and a goal
and objective so on 31 July 1982 at the
University of Tennessee in Knoxville he
was on my right shoulder my mom was on
my left shoulder and they pen 2nd
lieutenant bars on me and now today his
grandson dad passed in 1986 but his
grandson is a major United States Army
so that's four generations and how many
years did you serve 22 long time yeah
Chad what about you well uh three
generation Marine Corps family my father
served as a combat marine in Vietnam as
an infantryman and my son is now in
Afghanistan right now put a third
anglich oh yeah supporting the Georgians
in Afghanistan so and I was a marine as
well when they deployments to
Afghanistan so I uh my father being a
marine I suffered with a lot of things
that we help alert with at a foundation
and he came home he's
angry guy a lot of alcohol physical
abuse and so I grew up in a very
dysfunctional home I had a brother as a
year older than me and we were about 13
and 14 years old we decided we were
joined a military to escape that life
and so we both started running and
swimming and teamed up to prepare for
that kind of that goal in life and
unfortunately about a year after that my
brother was shot and killed and so it
put me in a very what I had left of a
family dissolved it put me in an extreme
isolation and in that isolation I just
continued to focus towards that goal
have been in the military and when I was
17 years old I'm in a Marine Corps crew
named sergeant Brown who I hadn't even I
wasn't going to graduate high school
live I was living on my own by that time
and I wanted to be in some type of
Special Operations and I expressed to
him you know what I wanted to do and he
told me about being a reconnaissance
marine so I set my sights on that and so
a Marine Corps for me Joey at 17 years
old was a clean slate of life and ran
your chance and at that young age I was
aware enough to embrace it and it's been
an amazing part of my life yeah what do
you think that regular people that don't
serve who love America you can see I've
got a giant American flag in the control
room we've got another one right over
there we've got the constitution and the
declaration independence in there what
do you think that regular Americans
should know about you guys people that
serve that maybe we don't know what one
I don't I don't think people often
realize how special it is for someone
who serves in the military currently we
only have a half a percent 0.5 percent
of our population the United States
serves in the military and he o stands
in the gap not just to protect the
freedoms that we have in America but to
protect the interests of others around
the world to stand up for people that
can't stand up for themselves that's one
of things always loved about the
military and I think people don't
understand is the fact that we do serve
as strength for the world not just our
nation able to protect you know these
people around the world that don't have
the ability to defend themselves yeah
we're gonna get into some of the the
policy parts of that what do you think
we should know about you guys that maybe
we don't I think the most important
thing and you know my Christian faith is
very strong in my life when you go to
John chapter 15 verse 13 where it says
that no greater love has an
the man that he will lay down his life
for another then also in Isaiah six and
eight when Isaiah is there with the host
of the Lord and and there saying whom
shall we sin who will go for us and
Isaiah says here am I send me
we have to understand that the freedoms
and liberties that we have here in the
United States of America is that we
because we consistently raised
generations of these young men and women
that are going to continue to give that
last full measure of devotion and that's
why Abraham Lincoln talked about the
increased devotion that a nation should
have for those in the Gettysburg Address
and so when people come up and say thank
you for your service I mean that's all
fine and well but I think the real
tribute and the real honor to people
like Chad myself and all the generations
that have worn a uniform is we want you
to understand why we took an oath to
support and defend the Constitution do
you guys think that there is a little
rebirth of that happening right now
because it's not a coincidence that I
put the flag there in the Constitution
and the Declaration of Independence I
don't think it's a coincidence that as
people have watched me sort of evolved
politically and talk about these things
and pride in the country and those
things I don't mean blind pride I mean
you know really understanding where we
came from and where we're going
I do see a rebirth of that now are you
seeing that I am and I said that's just
just recently at a speaking event I
think when people turn on the news they
think you know the country has lost its
way but that's just I think those
allowed and voiced and allowed few when
I go around the country and speak about
the work that we do and and supporting
our warriors I get to witness firsthand
a grateful nation of Americans who are
patriots they love their warriors they
love their country and a and they would
kind of have the same views that you
have that it's a special place and and
it's a sacred place that we need to
uphold the values that we have in this
nation yeah I know you have no love lost
there the mainstream media but do you
think that it partially is that that
they've sort of gone so bananas and I'm
making it seem that America is so evil
and we're patriarchal and racist and all
all these ridiculous things that
eventually you push good people to say
whoa whoa whoa yeah no we're not and
that's actually good no and it is I
don't think that you know is so
interesting you and I were talking
off-camera how you said five or six
years ago you thought I was a nut
and now we're sitting here having a
great conversation yeah and I think all
of us if we really understand the
objective truths about this country we
come to realize what America really is
it's a beacon of Liberty freedom of a
democracy that's why people come here
when I lived in South Florida I never
saw anyone get on a boat to go to Cuba
right okay no one is leaving they'll
leave they don't leave Guatemala El
Salvador Honduras to go to Venezuela so
you know this is a very simple thing so
when you have someone like a Governor
Cuomo the stance of a says oh you know
America has never been great tell that
to those men who's 75 years ago landed
on those beaches in Normandy and jumped
in you know the night prior tell that to
your dad and my older brother who fought
in those jungles in Vietnam tell that to
my dad
go to his you know final resting spot a
man that fought for this country when
this country did not afford him all
those rights and privileges it did
others mmhmm yeah he wanted his son to
still be an officer in that exact same
army that's America
that's what it's all about Dave so how
do you balance that which I think we
obviously all agree with with that also
we do make mistakes
also we're flawed also depending on
political leadership there might be
times when you're really all gung-ho
about all of our policies and sometimes
you're not yeah I mean I think as a
nation we are gonna we are like you said
you're not you know what people leaving
to go to Cuba I mean we have a line from
Guatemala to to San Diego people to come
here and there for a reason it's not
just for free health care and in college
you're coming here because about this
land of opportunity it still isn't and
and I prayed always well it will be but
we're not going to do things right all
the time we're not gonna have leaders
that are always gonna make the right
decisions but I believe America as an
institution this great the great
experiment of America is something that
still stands true and and it's the
reason why you know the world looks to
books towards us and America as a nation
and as a military the strength of it
that makes the world a better place what
do you think it is fundamentally about
the military that allows it to keep
America strong despite having
administrations that can wildly go in
different directions I mean just look at
the last two those are the policies
Bhama versus the policies of Donald
Trump are
vastly different but we haven't had a
coup you know the military is still
functioning still doing its job what
what is where does that strength come
from well if you go and you read the
Constitution you know the founding
fathers talked about moving toward a
more perfect union so we're not a
perfect country but we understand that
we have a foundation we have a
fundamental you know values we have a
rule of law that enables us to move in
that direction that's how we continue to
amend ourselves and that's the
interesting thing about military dave is
that we don't take an oath to a
political party we don't take a note to
a person we take a note to that document
that you know I'm carrying right here
that unifies us as a nation that that's
our rule of law that's our standard and
so our military is focused on that and
nothing more and we are the guardians of
the Republic that's that's how we really
see ourselves and it's important that
our country sees us that way also so no
we're not gonna go in and throw a coup
because one administration to the others
but you know maybe there are gonna be
some orders that are not exactly ethical
that we will stand up and challenge and
that's why we have these generals and
that's what we expect them to do as the
members of the Joint Chiefs of Staff but
we we take that oath to the Constitution
and I think that's important so let's
talk a little bit about your service
specifically so you served in
Afghanistan you served in Iraq you know
Afghanistan seems to me to be the
weirdest military adventure or war
whatever you want to call it at this
point because it's the longest ongoing
war that we've ever had in the universe
it's still going on now people seem to
be very confused as to why we went in
the first place why are we still there
sort of break that down well I think
that I feel a lot clearer more clear
about Afghanistan or why we went there I
mean great September September 11th you
know planes were flown into World Trade
Center and it was done so by the Taliban
and we had a we had an obligation to go
and hunt down Osama bin Laden in the
Taliban that were responsible for it and
part of that meant to align with the
north alliance which would have been a
Massoud would have been the leader of
the North Alliance which bin Laden
clever
we killed at the same time assassinated
at the same time and so as we went to
Afghanistan we had to you know not just
go after one person but we had to had to
go the the infiltration of the
Afghanistan by the Taliban occupation of
that and so going after going after the
Taliban meant a occupying of Afghanistan
not to overtake the country but to
eradicate Taliban Anette and obviously
that's still going on 20 years later my
I would never thought after eight
deployments there my son we are there
fighting the Taliban right so is that is
that a failure of our policy is there an
inconsistency between administration's
there what do you think that is let me
know yet think at eight years for eight
years of doing this of that twenty years
the military was completely handcuffed
they were there their cut cut
resources manpower and and rules of
engagement that were not favorable to
our troops and that's you're talking I'm
talking about them bomb administration
at the cost of many American lives and
uh and I truly believe that the
administration is responsible for that
and luckily now the rules of engagement
have changed and we're able to go after
and more offensively go after the
Taliban and I think we're having a more
effective footprint there however I
think Americans should understand that
we're not there as a in the same
capacity we was in the early days we
were there to support the AMA the Afghan
National Army we're there to support
other allied forces such as my son right
now is assigned to the Georgians who
were out doing combat patrols and
presence patrols
so we're there more of a support and
advise capacity right now yeah and and I
think even with my son Aaron loved him
to come home but I think we belong there
in that capacity to support advice and
help help for nations because these
nations like they and they they can't if
we left they in a Afghan National Army
to do this themselves they would they
would fail so that actually is a good
segue to talking about Iraq because one
of the things that happened Iraq you
served in in Desert Storm but after this
last Iraq war you know there was this
big debate when do we when do we leave
and basically Obama took us out with
just announcing the day we're going and
they were having free and fair elections
there was actually the beginnings of a
democracy there now you could argue that
we maybe we should have never been there
place you could argue that we had to
leave no matter what you call those
things but democracy was spreading and
then we left it now it's gotten much
worse so actually first why do you talk
about a desert storm just in general
because that's that's the Forgotten one
now because people only think about this
the second round you know it's it's
incredible that that has happened and
one of the committees I sit on is to
establish the National Desert Storm War
Memorial in Washington DC and so because
it has been forgotten but it was an
important bridge from us coming from
Vietnam to once again reestablished that
respect to regard for our military but
there will never be another Desert Storm
no one is ever going to take on the
United States of America and a wide-open
desert of conventional warfare you know
two of the best training facilities for
our military is right here in California
two to nine of Palms and then also the
National Training Center we are experts
in open desert warfare and the Iraqi
army learned that in 96 short hours but
the real thing was that we built a
coalition we you know held to the
objective that we were going in on the
United Nations mandate it was to get the
Iraqis out of Kuwait but what you have
seen metastasized now is a world that
understands you don't fight the United
States of America you know up front
face-to-face now you have this
ideological war against Islamic jihadism
they don't wear uniforms they don't
openly declare themselves they are
non-state non uniform religious and
that's what you know Chad had to deal
with in Afghanistan and even after I
retired I was in Afghanistan for
two-and-a-half years as a civilian
military advisor down in Kandahar we
have to we have not done a good job of
understanding this modern battlefield
understanding this enemy that we're
facing even Russia you know when they
went into the Crimea they didn't go in
as the Russian military they went as a
paramilitary force and you see what
they're doing in Ukraine China when you
look at what they're doing all over the
globe they do say that this is our
strategy the one belt one road but they
are covertly doing things that we don't
understand China is in Venezuela as a
matter of fact Iran the number one state
sponsor of Islamic terrorism in the
world but you know Hezbollah is not out
there really
you know declaring a in their estate or
what have you and I said oh they are
flying their flags and let it fly the
flag but you know Hezbollah doesn't have
a country and so I think that we the the
the incredible thing I got to be at the
tactical level and then also I got to be
at the strategic level having sat on the
House Armed Services Committee and just
the same in Vietnam we lose
strategically we don't lose tactically
on the ground it's at that level with
the policies and everything where we
make some really dumb decisions
you know rules of engagement not
understanding the enemy their goals and
objectives that you know it filters down
and we set our warriors up not for
success and I think that's what we have
to learn what do you make of the fact
that George HW Bush this sort of the
famous moment where he decided not to go
to Baghdad not to topple Saddam the
first time around he was obviously under
pressure for more of the neocon types to
take Saddam out at that point the irony
being that we left Saddam and then we
just his son ended up going in yeah 15
years later so what was it like to be
there when that decision it was
incredibly was made or not made
depending on you want to look at it yeah
because I was in the 1st Infantry
Division and we were the ones that had
secured Safwan airfield for the peace
negotiation talks to come in and we just
sat there that night and said man ok so
major lieutenant colonel when you think
we'll be back because any time you fight
half-measure warfare you have ongoing
residual consequences I mean you look at
the Korean War you look at the Vietnam
War the last time we fought a total war
was World War two when we wanted the
enemy to capitulate I mean they sign a
document of surrender we don't have that
today so you you believe in the power of
doctrine basically that you're gonna do
it you just you got to do it right
absolutely absolutely and and that's
what Carl von Clausewitz talked about he
said War is about imposing your will
upon another you don't still do half
will now with Desert Shield Desert Storm
we would have lost credibility though if
we had continued on but I think that we
did not do a good job of decorating the
complete capacity and capability
militarily of Saddam Hussein because we
had to their Republican Guard divisions
just right ahead of us we could have
taken those
guys out and maybe brought him to an
even better position at the table but do
you think the military brass wanted to I
don't know these are the people there I
think I think the thing is we kind of
felt we didn't seal the deal and we kind
of knew that eventually come back but
even more so we could have done better
with the Kurds I really feel that we
continue to kind of you know
back-slapping occurs when they are so
pro-american and and they so want to be
an ally of ours and and what we have
done with Isis couldn't have done
without the Kurds yeah is that just one
of those situations where Iraq really is
three countries yeah and it's like all
right we could I suppose we could impose
some sort of partition and give the
Kurds what they justly deserve that then
we'll probably make turkey rain hell on
them and a bunch of other things you
know well turkey is not exactly our
friends on earth one if you go back
post-world War one the sykes-picot
treaty when the great powers of England
and France went and they just divided
the Middle East up arbitrarily just the
same as you saw in Africa you know they
didn't pay attention to tribal
allegiances and what-have-you they
created artificial nations the lines
actually look ridiculous you know if you
really look at them they have the shapes
and all of these things there so I think
that there's an opportunity now for us
to maybe look at how can the Middle East
be restructure I mean the Kurds are the
nation's largest ethnic group without a
homeland and and I think that they have
suffered
you know from increased persecution I
think that they could be more friendly
to you know their Syrian Christians the
Chaldeans who are also persecuted and so
I think that's where you you know we
don't do strategy in long terms we do
strategy and election cycles day yeah
and you can't win that's just the part
of this that probably never changes they
almost screws up everything and it does
grew up everything because you can't win
against people that are thinking of 50
and a hundred years cycles so so with
all that in mind if we look at
Afghanistan today and now you're saying
some of the rules of engagement have
changed we're doing things a little more
effectively how do we eventually not BNF
is there any road that you can see to
getting us there died I don't think
there's any successful road as a
complete full withdrawal I think I think
we need we probably will maintain a base
there maybe Balcom Basin and continue to
support in this advisory role so I have
to say this my capacity in Afghanistan
was much different than the conventional
troop I was a I was a Force Recon marine
I had the unique opportunity try out for
a JSOC the Joint Special Operations
Command Task Force and so the capacity I
worked in was I didn't live on a base I
lived out with Afghan people I was
embedded with Afghan people and we're
still being closed and and so I lived in
their homes and a dinner with their
families and what did what did they
think about you guys well they look
that's that this is a point they love
the fact that America was there because
they had been truly oppressed by the
Taliban and and so I got at first when I
first went I was I deployed like every
other warrior after 9/11 we were going
there to right the wrongs of 9/11 that's
a very patriotic cause that's what
motivated us but very quickly I went
from that to understanding what these
people had endured from the Taliban to
see their hurt and their pain and their
what what the Taliban have done to the
women and and the little kids little
boys and little girls and and seeing
this and hearing about stories and
understanding this it really turned my
heart from this patriotic sense of
retaliate for 9/11 - these people are
pressed and we need to be there that
home these people and that's where I'm
torn today because I still have a heart
for these people I mean I I lost Afghan
brothers like in combat that uh and so I
still have a heart for these people and
and can imagine I couldn't imagine I was
there for the 2004 election I remember
sitting in a living room everyone's like
a Super Bowl party everyone's tune in TV
because John Kerry and and Bush's as and
everyone these guys be these people have
this food everywhere they having this
giant party I never seen anything like
no one in the United States excited for
a presidential election like this was
and and when Bush won they were so
excited because they were so terrified
that if Kerry won he would withdraw the
US troops what would happen to them they
know they know what'll happen to them if
we leave and and so it really changed my
perspective on being there again as a
father now and with
I'm like that's my son blowing there it
made me ask these questions all over
again but I do believe that we don't
belong there in a in a conventional
capacity but as us as a support and
advising role I do believe we don't so
with that in mind what is a sound policy
what is a sound foreign policy that you
can do some good you can try to build
the not nation builders just yeah but
try to set the seeds of democracy and
freedom which we were doing in our act
which we're doing in Afghanistan but
make sure that we don't become the
imperial Empire forever mired down so so
what do you think just broadly because
we're started talking about this at a
personal level from your perspective
what do you think broadly just a sane
foreign policy well that's the key thing
it should not be about nation-building
it should be about you know strike
operations is about having a force that
is able to make sure that these Islamic
jihadists are not able to have a defined
sanctuary and base of operations and
what we have been doing up to this point
Dave we've been playing whack-a-mole and
you can't win playing whack-a-mole so
what we need to be able to do is instead
of having this massive forward deployed
military you have a power projection
platform and so you have you know AB
Algrim you have a base you know
somewhere close in Iraq where you can
launch troops very quickly and you have
a strike operation you hit a critical
capability capacity of the enemy and you
know then you pull back but you stay in
that very basic region to let them know
that we can quickly respond once again
and that's what you just saw when we
brought into the carrier group into into
the the Persian Gulf area to stand up
against Iran to say that we do have a
credible military deterrent so your
foreign policy is worthless unless you
have that deterrent and and they teach
you in Staff College about the four
elements of military army and national
power diplomatic informational military
and economic and I think that what we
have to do is continue to use the
diplomatic the informational the
economic means first and foremost but we
have to show that you know
push comes to shove we can do this if
you're not willing to so with that in
mind do you regard the Obama red line in
Syria as just like the biggest the
biggest blunder of things I remember I
was a lefty at the time you can watch
videos of me on The Young Turks I was
saying we should not be there I was
saying I don't that they've got to take
care of it though or the regional actors
have to take care of it let Turkey help
some of these people like I did not want
anything to do with that I was
completely anti-war but then once Obama
said the red line thing I was like all
right well if you if you set the deal
here then you have to follow through do
you view that as just I don't know has
there been a worse blunder of let's say
just said well if you lose all
credibility whatsoever and then people
see you as a joke
I mean when you come on you say Isis is
just a JV team then you know you're
saying that I'm dismissing this thing
when you deal with someone like Kim Jong
Un's saying we're gonna have strategic
patience well the guy keeps shooting off
rockets and missiles and everything like
that so you know compromise appeasement
negotiation things like that you know
there are people in the world that the
only understand strengthen Mike and Chad
and I we've seen those type of people we
understand that anything else is deemed
it's weakness so when you draw a red
line then all of a sudden you say well
run really my red line it was everybody
else's red line you know leaders take
responsibility and that's what you know
you failed to see then now we have
someone that has come in he's saying
okay rules of engagement got to change
you generals you're going you take care
you do what has to be done we don't hear
about Isis now they still exist as an
ideological enemy but they don't have a
territorial integrity you know you have
China that is now saying you know what
is going on here I mean we just had the
run of the mill for all of these years
Republican or Democrat president now
something has changed North Korea the
same thing even Russia is starting to be
concerned so I think that's the
important thing is you know you have to
be able to come out with that stick when
it is required when it is necessary and
if you create a void like President
Obama did in Iraq
someone's gonna fill that void that's a
law of physics so I think we got some
hints as to what Cornel West thinks
about Trump's policy you know foreign
policy what do you think
well I think you know all four areas
that you're talking about particularly
in economic sanctions right now I mean a
lot of people you know continue that
every time the president says something
that he's gonna impose these impose
tariffs or or do economic sanctions
people laugh and mock him but it turns
around weeks later you know but then so
many I think he keeps pushing these
these things both military military
strategy and diplomacy and economic and
and you seen him win in these areas and
uh you know this could be becoming hard
to doubt the president yeah
what do you think about his
decision-making abilities when it comes
to selecting certain people so I
remember like when Bolton got put in
yeah it was like all right now Trump's
going all neocon and the base which was
very anti-war was very pissed and I
remember sort of thing well it's like
that doesn't mean you're going neocon
because you bring a guy like him around
it actually means you're bringing
somebody around that is known as a
threat that kinda keeps the enemies
going we don't and then you have trump
who says anything wait a minute combo
here is a guy who we think likes war or
who does like we're let's say or however
you want to phrase that plus a guy like
trump who says whatever he wants now we
don't know how to react basically and
that is the thing no one understands
that decision cycle so people are
completely off-base they don't know what
it's going to come out you know in the
morning their Center I said okay what is
it going to tweet now and in the marine
corps because I did three years on
exchange with the Marines they call it
the OODA loop and what you want to do is
to be able to get inside the enemy's
decision cycle and you want to
completely throw them off off their
their game and that's what President
Trump has done you know you know you
think he really gets that at a military
level there's a New York thing they
might be well I think it's sort of I
always say it's more like he's just kind
of and I don't even mean this I don't
even truly don't even mean this
negatively necessarily but he's kind of
just a crooked New York businessman but
you got to do a lot of stuff within the
hill a lot of stuff we got to do a lot
of stuff within that to make things
happen because the whole system is out
of whack and see a normal politician is
gonna follow what everyone says okay you
gotta do X you know to do y I got a
doozy I mean they got the set battle
scheme or whatever and he just has
completely selling that playbook out and
folks aren't used to that he is not
predictable
and really on the battlefield you don't
want to be predictable and this is a
Bala this is an economic battlefield
this is a diplomatic battlefield it's a
military battlefield and he is just
completely out maneuvering our major
adversaries China Russia Iran North
Korea in the world in a better place
because of it right now do you think
that's empirically true but I mean if
you listen to the media it sounds like
you know any moment World War 3 is gonna
happen where something's going down with
China Iran is gonna get the bomb this
that the other thing but do you really
feel that there's empirical proof that
actually things are safer or more stable
well I mean we have I mean what's north
North Korea going to do what's wrong I'm
gonna do we have no you know we no way
to predict what they're going to do but
I think the actions that the president
and the administration has has proven
that they they are responding to I mean
North Korea is responded in a way that
you know we've never thought they would
respond to with the relationship
ron has back down Mexico who's you know
really taking advantage of a the United
States over many many years it's finally
coming around I mean these these things
may seem extreme because people weren't
used to it and and but I think they're I
believe the world is a better place
right now yeah what do you think of
think about this day the president said
I do not want to see people dropping
bombs on innocent women and children and
he bombed Syria now from a tactical
level you know you looked at the battle
damage assessment it was not really a
big thing but the fact that he took the
action that was the the the most
important thing I mean when Iran starts
to maybe do a little saber rattling he
doesn't you know get back on his heels
he says send a care of battle group and
and and let's show them that you know
we'll go toe-to-toe you're not going to
see sailors on a river and assault boat
on their knees at gunpoint mm because of
the Iranian Revolutionary Guard Navy
that ain't happened right which we saw
which we saw and every American you
talked about the Flay every American
should have been incensed that we had
sailors who surrendered instead of
fought and while on their knees at
gunpoint to the Iranians yeah well that
must be why Trump wanted what within two
months of being elected he dropped that
mother
of all bombs and people were like oh now
he's he's going all Warhawk but your
argument would be he did it because it's
like you show a little bit of erratic
behavior you put your shield strength
too and that keeps these guys on their
heels what do you guys make of our
alliances and the way they really sort
of shifted over the last five years
let's say and just what's going on with
NATO and the United Nations I mean Trump
has basically obliterated the United
Nations NATO is shifting and that more
than that that if we don't do anything
nobody does anything and that that is
the sort of bargain that the United
States in that's that's very difficult
do you think that's a fair thing to say
if we don't do anything internationally
no one does anything what NATO sure
doesn't sure it isn't I mean uh I mean
the UN has you know proven to be I think
exposed at this point as they will in US
and so yeah I mean America has had to
step up and fill the gap but I think
also the president is a kind of expose
that that we everyone needs to come to
the table one and contribute and you
know he's released really I called them
out that day the UN summit I think it
was a UN summit where he really exposed
them on this and so yeah but I do
believe that there's American does have
responsibility to fill the gap I don't
believe we're in a nation-building and
and handle ever brought me to be a
firefighter for every fire in the world
but I do believe we have a
responsibility as a strongest nation in
the world yeah why don't other countries
step up it doesn't seem like anyone
steps up anymore like they all say they
like to hate us and then they ask us for
help and then sometimes we overstepped
the line and now the gets worse I mean
there's this crazy bargain always
happening because we've been that
security blanket for them for so long
you know my first tour dude it was over
in Europe and you know I was part of a
NATO unit and when you looked at you
know the other airborne units were part
at NATO you know you just kind of
scratch your heels like you know dudes
what are y'all doing y'all even train I
mean you can't hit the you know the
broadside of a barn you know but these
collective body politics United Nations
European Union I think they're being
rejected and now when you look at the
security organizations like NATO
President Trump has gone in and said hey
guys
whiskey-tango-foxtrot when he called out
Angela Merkel for having a deal with
Russia
for natural gas and now you're asking me
to protect you from Russia but you're
doing economic deals with Russia
come on does that make sense and
furthermore you're not owning up to your
2% responsibility of financing in NATO I
will tell you when I was in Afghanistan
the biggest problem for the German army
was obesity because they were just
saying you know good sausage and bread
and everything they weren't getting out
they weren't fighting anyone in southern
Afghanistan we had the Brits we had the
Canadians we had the Romanians and we
had the Dutch and they each had a
separate province and each of them had
their own rules of engagement or you
know orders from the Ministry of Defence
they didn't coordinate within each other
and so the Taliban would just easily
understood what we can do this and in
this problem is because the Dutch are
not going to drop bombs on us they're
just gonna fly over our heads and you
know be real loud so at that point NATO
doesn't have a have a standard operating
procedures are all doing something to
all their base upon their respective
ministries of Defense everyone knew that
the Romanians the orders for the
Romanians they could not lead the roads
they could not get out of their vehicles
Wow
so I mean how you gonna win against the
enemy when you have your Ministry of
Defence dictating all of these different
you know is that changing under NATO now
well I haven't been back to Afghanistan
since 2008 or seven so I wouldn't know
but I think that you know maybe when you
look at the Georgia's we're going out
and doing patrols maybe it is different
but these major NATO member countries
they're not stepping up and I wouldn't
even begin to question why we have
Turkey and NATO because Iran is not a
friend to Western civilization but the
other countries are stepping up because
of what you said I mean as the u.s.
comes back and moves to that support and
advisory capacity then they have to have
to do their part I mean this is a strong
presidential administration saying that
hey you guys gonna do your role we're
not gonna go out there and do all these
combat person terrible American wars do
all these combat patrols why you sit
back on a base this is a minute strategy
and shift of the military and the
administration yeah you see a big surge
in a special operations community and
that support an advisory role too so
let's let's shift to veterans because I
think that that's what brings you guys
really together
how did you guys meet by the way was it
was it through the nonprofit how do you
mean how do I think you needed some army
friends yeah call me up now we're in the
same circles of people and we have
mutual friends and we both have a very I
mean absolute both Patriots and level
warriors and and after outside a uniform
were both so serving and we are you know
kinder kinder heart and hearts to do
this mission yeah so you started mighty
mighty yes can you tell us a little bit
about that and and colonel s sits on the
board yeah maybe it's it's it's hard to
tell you without Jerry limited my story
you know after my eighth deployment
Afghanistan I was diagnosed with
post-traumatic stress disorder to give
you a kind of how that started for me it
started with a you know just coming home
and being frustrated angry I have a wife
and three I've been married for 24 years
and three amazing children and and they
really endure me coming home and just
being a tyrant to them you know lots of
verbal abuse and never physical abuse
but throwing things breaking things is
acting like a lunatic around my house
did you know something was wrong with
you where were you aware of it enough I
was I tell you when at first like I was
that anger intensity worked really well
in Afghanistan like I said that Afghans
I worked with they hated the Taliban the
task force I was on was a kind of biking
kind of war culture mindset and so it
worked really well Afghanistan but 24
hours later when I'd be home wife and
children I didn't work well there I
couldn't like flip a switch and turn it
off so I recognized that but it was a
moment that I came home from my from
Afghanistan I made it home for my
daughter's birthday she was so excited I
was gonna be there and I remember she's
very opinionated and she still is and
she didn't like the icing on her cake
and just saying that like I flipped out
and I grabbed my little girl's birthday
cake and picked it up and threw it
against the wall and destroyed my little
girl's birthday and I remember in that
moment thinking like what kind of person
doesn't looking at dad does something
like that and and that was one example
but at that moment I realized that they
just back off instead of fixing the
behavior I just kind of distance myself
and so between these eight deployments I
would just stay busy at schools and
training and work ups and just stayed
busy and isolated myself from them and
over time that anger started turning
anxiety I started having these
physiological symptoms my arms would go
numb my face would going down might feel
like my throat was swelling shut
sometimes I feel like I had like a
thousand pounds on my chest and I
started researching what the this was
and I learned it was panic attacks and
but I didn't want to say anything that
the guys have worked with and it's a
little smush Special Operations Group I
figured the guys would think I was weak
maybe I lose my clearance and so I
didn't I didn't speak up I tried to push
it down and do my job and eventually
those symptoms got much worse I actually
started having these moments where I
almost felt like a detached like
out-of-body experience I wake up by
these fogs and realized I didn't
remember the last few weeks and so I had
to speak up and say something because I
wasn't only put myself in danger but I
was putting other people in danger as
well and so that's when I was brought
home and I was diagnosed with
post-traumatic stress disorder and that
began that wasn't my rock bottom but I
began a very downward spiral in my life
my wife and my psychologists and we're
trying to help me move forward and I was
in such a state of the only way I really
know how to describe like the state of
panic that I was in I just recently kind
of came up with words for it it's like
if you were like ankle was handcuffed to
the bottom of a pool drain and yeah I
got like the surface was about a foot
above your head and you had just how
desperate you would be for one breath of
air but you never drown you never die
like that's how I was like 24/7 and on
top of that panic I felt totally ashamed
because I was so proud of the job I was
doing and my whole identity was wrapped
in that job and that was gone and so my
wife and my counselor we're trying to
find something for me to do and that's
where the MMA and jujitsu came in I'd
say I did it since I was little but I'm
still a little yeah since I was five
years old and Wow and so I was already
professional fighters so I dove into
that and just invested my time in that
and I had a great newest success that
was ended being 18 and 2 as a pro
fighter I won a world title belt Legacy
FC and formed Strikeforce and always
shows but really what I did was I never
got well I found something to hide in
like somebody went climbing a bottle
alcohol or drugs for me that's where I
just just made myself occupied and so
eventually uh do you think that's where
most people are at when they start
getting into MMA because as you know
obviously yeah absolutely blowing up and
and Joe Rogan's talking all the fighters
all the time and there really seems to
be this this thing about getting your
[ __ ] together that that seems to be the
beginning point
what's a distance
gonna be discipline like everything
around I mean I'm computing I was
telling my last today he's like you
still compete I'm a competing jiu-jitsu
term that's doing the world's World
Championships and August and the reason
why is because it helps me regimen my
life like it's something I put a date on
the calendar and everything in my life
becomes discipline the way my family
life is the way I eat the way I sleep it
brings some red the way I manage my
schedule for traveling and speaking
everything becomes reg a minute so I try
to compete like twice a year for that
when you live in the lifestyle of a
professional fighter and competing at
that very high level like I competed
that it really helped me manage my life
and my life was I was still kneeling
panic attacks I was still angry I was
still my life was still kind of in
disarray and and my marriage really
began to deteriorate because it wasn't
addressing the problem and so eventually
I ended up in an affair I didn't care my
white I was so callous at that point and
somewhat we sat our kids down and said
we were getting divorced and I my wife
filed for divorce we sold our home moved
into separate apartments like sign
12-month leases and my wife and I had
two very different reactions and my wife
went into that church and I don't mean
like on a Sunday she went like every day
got connected with a group of people and
she said she started praying for me and
at that time I was prize floor away from
God if she could possibly be in and but
I asked her now of course what was she
praying for me at this time and she just
pray God let me see Chad the way you see
Chad let me love Chad the way you love
Chad let me forgive Chad to eat free
game Chad and so yeah this woman that's
like fighting for me meanwhile I'm in
this apartment immediately like I'm
separated from this woman don't have to
deal with anymore
I don't be responsible for that the
problems always causing anymore and so I
had a big fight on Showtime Strikeforce
and and that's what I was focused on and
when that fight was over I ended up
winning that fight but as I won that
fight in the Toyota Center is like ten
thousand people were there and I
remember thinking oh my hand was raised
like my wife wasn't there and she'd
always been my cheerleader before mmm
something about that I went back to my
apartment that night and I started
thinking about all the problems that
call us the people I hurt my family
mainly and I thought well I blamed
everyone else before like I was the
common denominator
like it was the problem with me and when
I came to this thought I this idea came
over me that somehow my family would be
sad without me but they would be better
off now if you know anything about the
veteran
suicide rate that same hopeless thought
finds a home in the hearts of 20-plus
veterans every day that not I'm gonna
kill myself to escape my pain but you
know somehow you think that people
around me be sad my family be sad my
friends will be sad but they're gonna be
better off and so that decision really
seemed like it made sense to me and I
made a decision to take my life I had a
in that apartment I had all my family
pictures I'm ashamed to say but it's
true I and all my family pictures in my
closet because you know girls coming
over why not
and so I I would sit in my closet with
my I shut the door and I put my family
pictures on the floor and I try to build
up the courage I put the pistol to my
and a Glock 22 pistol I put it to my my
head I put it in my mouth trying to
build up the courage and I don't know to
this day if I had the courage to
actually pull the trigger because I
didn't but what did keep me from doing
it was my son Hunter the one that's in
Afghanistan right now he had the only
key to my apartment and I knew he'd be
the one either find me or open the door
for someone to find me and that kept me
from actually doing it
one morning I called my wife she says
that call she said I was frantic I don't
really remember the call but she came to
my apartment and when she came I was
actually in the closet with that pistol
and and she knocked on my door and
unwittingly you know intervened and
saved my life I remember hiding the
pistol under my blanket well I wanted to
find it and she I answered the door and
we got in this confrontation and she
asked me a question that ever radically
changed my life she asked me how I could
do everything I did in the Marine Corps
she saw me become a recon marine let me
train for these deployments and all
these things in Afghanistan and trained
for MMA fights cutting weight and all
the discipline it takes to do that she's
like how could you do all of that and
when it comes to your family you'll quit
and that question for me to be called a
quitter which is one of those so cutting
words to me it just impacted me and you
had to make a change so Wow alright
there's a lot there so well first off
thank you for being so upfront about the
personal stuff because I know that's not
easy for anybody so before we get to
mighty oaks then I'm sure you have heard
many many stories that are like that did
you ever experience anything along those
lines did you ever go down that path
no me personally you know I it was just
different for me
I have a very supportive wife who her
dad was career military also did 24
years in the army and in Vietnam two
tours and he's buried at Arlington
National Cemetery so we always tried to
have that very strong support and as a
battalion commander I remember when
before we went to Iraq you know I tried
to tell the soldiers that the person
that you are here when you put your
first step on those stairs to go into
that airplane you gotta leave that
person here and the person that you are
over there somehow you've got to leave
that person over there and I think that
that's what the struggle is for our
warriors to be able to to make that
switch it's not saying that you're cold
and callous to be able to do it but you
just understand what's required of you
you know your nation is calling you to
be a certain person but your family is
also causing you calling you to be a
certain person and and that's what
veterans and that's what our military
men and women are struggling with
because we put them in these very
intense combat situations and then we
extricate them from them and we put them
back into the family and I don't think
we do a really good job of the
decompression time over there before
they come back home I think that you
need a good two to three weeks before
you know as you're coming out of those
combat zones of operation before you
come home and it's important that they
talk to each other we don't we don't
allow that to do we do none of that I
mean they're well we travel across the
world take some time but you you mean
some like real time over there and and
you know instead of rushing we've got to
get them back home you know we got to
get all the equipment loaded I'm getting
back home take the time a couple of
weeks to just let guys sit around and
talk and and get that opportunity to
leave that person over there and start
mentally preparing themselves to go back
because a lot has changed and your
families you've been gone you know your
wife your kids they've continued on with
their lives you you're kind of the one
that's coming back in then you're kind
of the guest yeah and you've got to you
know you know real cussing yourself it's
got to be a huge catch-22 though because
in their minds they're all going I want
to get home tomorrow yes get Mol
yeah but I think that in the long run it
would be so beneficial you know I
remember I did a year in Korea in 1995
and my daughter my oldest daughter when
I left nothing she was a little over a
year and you know that was the day
before Skype and everything like that
oh you sharing VHS tapes and
what-have-you but when I got back from
Korea you know she was there and she
looked at me and like I think I know who
you are who you are and so it was all
about redeveloping that relationship you
know taking her out you know
daddy-daughter time just just whatever
and then finally she realized okay this
is a guy I've been seeing you know on
those video tasting yeah he's my dad
he's not leaving he's not going anywhere
so I think it's important that we allow
our guys to have that time but we are
putting them as such a constant
deployment cycle and that's why I get so
upset about how we have reduced the the
strength of our military because we're
running these warriors we're running
their families into the ground and
that's why mighty oaks is so important
yeah so you handed me the segue talk
talk to me about why you started mighty
oaks well in that in that reaction I'm a
wife's question you know why would I not
fight for my my family and my own life I
had to respond to that and I and through
that response I found the solution that
many of our state's not just me we we I
knew I couldn't make those changes by
myself and you needed help and so I
asked my wife was there someone in this
church she was going to because I
because I knew I couldn't do it with the
people around me as well I had some
great friends but there were more people
had telling me what I wanted to hear and
not what I needed to hear and so I made
a man named Steve Toth and Steve is a
Texas State Legislature now and at the
time he was the elder at church more my
wife was going to in a small business
owner and we met at a Starbucks coffee
shop in him and I had a perfect plan of
how I was gonna fix my life and it was
really I was probably slid it over to
him really smug he put his hand on it
slid it right back over to me and told
me I was gonna fail and I remember being
like rev initially really offended
because I'm like it's pretty good and
really what I was trying to do is
manipulate him to say take this plan
show it to my wife because I'm trying to
fix things mm-hmm and he tapped on that
paper and he said if this thing doesn't
have anything to do with your
relationship with God I'm not gonna
waste your time and I'm not glad you
waste mine and I know a lot of people
may not
with with my faith or what I believe but
I'll tell you this I tried everything
and tried I've been through the I've
been through all the consoling all the
programs had been on the pills and tried
professional success I had been
successful financially and and my career
is athlete as instructor I had a
thousand students in my school that I
was teaching and so I had I tried all
those things and nothing that worked and
so it's time for me to try something
different
we have a saying I'm mighty oaks if what
you're doing isn't working then why not
try something different and so I trusted
this man Steve I surrendered my life to
God through his leadership and his
mentorship and things in my life start
to radically change I I found a
restoration hope for very first time had
hope in a very long time and I found
ultimately what I'm what I've been
searching for the whole time I'm all
life and that's purpose and that purpose
was to share when I discovered with
other people and that was somebody else
began through that process I learned
something really important that it
sounds so simple but to me it's it was
so profound that all these things that
happen to me my childhood Afghanistan
losing one of the best friends foster
parent and we served together for 10
years when he was killed and owner first
deployments all these things that had
happened to me didn't lead me to be in
that closet with my pistol man wouldn't
let me they were the choices I made in
response to those things and I still had
control of that I still had that control
the ability choose differently and as
cliche as it may sound I didn't have to
let my past to find my future I could
she was a different future moving
forward and in doing that part of that
future I chose moving forward was to
take what I discovered and share with
others it was like if I was dying of
cancer and this guy Steve gave me the
cure I had to share it I felt obligated
to share it and so that's how we started
mighty oaks we went ready at the time my
wife and I were still bleeding as a
family trying to heal but we both felt
passionate to do this in this mission
and I'm so thankful we did I mean to
date I've spoken to over a hundred
thousand active duty troops and bases
around the world my request to share
message on those resiliency I go to
Marine Corps boot camp the Marine Corps
allows me to speak at Marine Corps boot
camp to young warriors about resiliency
and spiritual resiliency and we run a
program program called a legacy program
it's a recovery program we have four
ranches in a California Ohio Virginia
and Texas we pay for everything
travel flights
all the program is totally free
active-duty veterans and spouses become
these programs we do 30 camps per year
and we've had 2,600 graduates from those
from those camps and so it's been been
absolutely incredible to take what the
lessons I've learned and realized that I
wasn't the only one I wasn't alone 22
veterans every day we're taking their
lives at the same time I was going
through this divorce rates and some
bases are up to 80 percent for combat
veterans like a lot of people having the
same issues I had I had the solution and
now now we we had this the most amazing
team people like Kona West on a board
and a general Boykin and we have a
sergeant major Marine Corps sergeant
major can who's great friend of both of
ours out shot us both about one shot
yeah we we I just have no amazing team
and staff to serve these warriors we
have a I think 14 full time staff
members in about 40 instructors that are
all combat veterans that it serve as
instructors of these programs this is
absolutely incredible there's so much
there so it's really interesting to me
that you said you tried everything else
and and faith is what works for you now
I assume that as a man of faith you hear
something like that and that doesn't
surprise you no it doesn't it absolutely
doesn't and and I think that you know in
the Bible it says that you can do all
things through Christ Jesus who
strengthens you and that's the message
we need to get out there you and I were
talking earlier about you know the
victim mentality and I always tell
people you got two choices in life you
be a victim or you be a Victoire and
that's why I hate Progressive Socialist
because it tells people that are going
to be victims and that's not what
America is about and even more so Dave
when you look at what is happening with
our young people in United States of
America right now the suicide rate it's
because they're searching for something
and and they're out there trying
everything they're on the internet
they're on the social media they're
playing the video games they they want
to be cool the drugs and everything that
the world says that you can have to to
make you accept it but there's just one
thing that can really feel that
emptiness in your heart and I think you
know we talked about an awakening in
this country I also see a faith
awakening in this country as well yeah
it's interesting I you guys probably
know I've been on tour with Jordan
Peters in the last year and a half or so
and you know he's not trying to sell
religion on anyone particularly but he
is trying to show the power of religious
stories of meaning the meaning and all
of the things that I think you're
talking about and I do see a rebirth of
that and it's been well I've actually
seen it all over the world because we've
traveled all over the world and it's
pretty fascinating to see firsthand
because it's not what the media shows
you and you know he's moving beyond this
you can't be around that for a year year
and a half and not be moved personally
out of that well that's one of the
things you know leftism is about secular
humanism because they don't want you to
believe that you can have faith and hope
and something other than the government
and when you look at what you know our
founders created when you look and read
John Locke's Second Treatise on
government natural rights theory your
inalienable rights are not dictated to
you by man it comes from a creator life
later they can take them from you but
they take you from that they didn't give
them to you and that's the thing that we
have to come to understand and that's
why you see this drive to move you know
faith out of the the mainstream in the
United States of America because they
don't want people to understand that you
know I don't have to wait for you to
give it to me okay it's already been
given to me you know I have the ability
to pursue my happiness Bernie Sanders
Kamala Harris Spartacus all you guys you
guys can't you know you can't guarantee
happiness for me and I think that's what
Chad is saying he went to all of these
other things to try to fill that hole in
his life and then Steve Toth told him
that here here's the answer I got the
Spartacus reference there I mean as
there as hopefulness because those
people that are coming to us half of
those people in active duty military
orders coming being sent from the
military they don't agree with the fact
that we're a faith-based program but
they're looking for solutions if 15
years ago the DoD and VA began just
pushing clinical programs we've had we
have a 1100 VA and DOD clinical programs
at the time the suicide rate was 16 a
day it's only gotten worse and and so
there the military the VA the veteran
community are looking for answers
and in faith-based programs like mighty
oaks have to have proven to be
successful we just finished a finished a
three year longitude data a doctoral
study and I could bore you with the
numbers from it but we did outperform
clinical trials in this independent
study I assume there are some secular
organizations that are doing very
similar things that probably have decent
success rates to you're just saying that
for for you and for people that are
like-minded that this works for you but
you don't have any inherent problem with
people doing it from a more know exactly
respect I don't I do be I do believe
that some of those some of those things
are gonna be short-lived when people go
and are inspired or motivated
inspiration motivation tend to fade
sustained faith faith and faith in a God
that created us tense is just sustained
and it gives you the resiliency to
bounce back so I do believe that
personally but however I've seen some
other great great programs out there I
just believe that that when you when
people make the decision to align their
lives with the lives that we were
created to live they find true
resiliency and true strength and real
hope and real purpose with my work and
we've seen that firsthand and thousands
of guys and not everyone that comes to a
program or matter-of-fact about half of
the people that come that program would
say they share our faith when they come
but you're looking for something that
they hadn't found anywhere else so the
this hour absolutely flew by so if I was
giving you guys each a closing statement
here how is it that you'd want that
average person out there to get involved
help help some of these wounded warriors
help help you guys get the mission out
there I think we did a little of it
again yeah a little of it here but but
what would you want people to do I think
it's the most important thing is just
don't go up and say thank you for your
service get to know a veteran they're
veterans we should not have homeless and
jobless veterans in the United States of
America and and if you know a veteran
that is out there alone environment to
your home show them the real love that
the love did they extend it to you that
they were going to lay down their life
for your freedom that's gonna be tough
to beat that I'd say you know if you are
a patriot you want to be part of a
grateful nation when you are gonna meet
that veteran and invite him into your
home have a place to point them to and
there's plenty of places out there
mighty oaks foundation is a place that
they can point people to as a resource
to help our warriors that are struggling
with suicide
divorce PTSD all those all those issues
and we're not only a resource but a free
one would cover all the costs of that so
free tool at your disposal as a grateful
nation of servo warriors any warriors
listening our spouses just you know
visit our website and again we'll take
care of you and the website is mighty
oaks programs org that's right yeah
all right it's been a pleasure guys
thank you mom thank you so much and I
should tell you considering five years
ago I thought you were a complete nut
bag I don't know I don't know if this
says now more about you about you know
what that's the thing you know you have
to stand strong and eventually light
will overcome now you ended the show
twice on earth and a solid no ties with
everybody
[Music]